now to jerusalem where clashes have
broken out at the funeral of a prominent
palestinian-american journalist israel
had tightened security ahead of the
service for sharing abu aklar expecting
thousands of mourners to attend the al
jazeera reporter was killed during an
israeli army raid on the janine refugee
camp in the occupied west bank al
jazeera says israeli forces shot the
report in the israeli army and says an
interim investigation couldn't determine
who fired the fatal bullet
we can join our correspondent tanya
crema who is near the ceremony at the
ceremony the cemetery in jerusalem where
shireen abu akla's funeral is taking a
place uh welcome what just tell us
what's going on there
yeah we saw a very moving uh procession
actually here uh hundreds if not
thousands of people here from
east jerusalem mainly paying their
respect to shireen abu akla taking her
from the church then here just right
behind me outside the city walls the old
city walls to the cemetery where she's
laid to rest alongside her parents that
came after a very disturbing beginning
of the funeral procession at the
hospital
when pallbearers
actually dropped the coffin for a moment
when police stormed in that there were
some clashes in east jerusalem at the
hospital there
there's still a lot of police presence
here the streets are mainly you know
closed off around the area but i have to
say no a lot of people came out today to
pay their respects for very well-known
very loved and very uh
most experienced
journalists here
from the region not just locally she
worked for al jazeera arabic she was the
face of al jazeera arabic for over 20
years reporting here
on the conflict but also on the impact
on this of this conflict on people here
you could always find her where things
were happening in the field so people
really it was important to them to come
out here uh because yesterday there was
another memorial official memorial
service uh in ramallah at the mukata
at the presidential
residence there
to pay to say goodbye to shireen abba
aklam
and how close are we to knowing how
shireen abu aklar met her death
well investigations are ongoing that's
what we are being told
the autopsy was performed on wednesday
evening by the palestinian
authority the coroner said there that
it's inconclusive they retrieved a
bullet
she was shot in the head we also
received today the
initial findings of an initial
investigation by the israeli army
they also said that it's not possible at
this stage to determine the source of
the gun fire which killed
our colleague shirin our acl
they said there were two possibilities
they're looking at that she was hit by
palestinian gunfire they maintained that
there was a crossfire in the area or
that she was
that there was fire from the side of the
israeli side but they said this is all
not conclusive this is
yet to be investigated there's a lot of
pressure i have to say also from the
international community also from the us
administration
to get to the bottom of that what
happened there
thank you for that to tanya tanya kramer
in jerusalem
you